bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui fait son miel des
déclarations bercy
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches on nous avait annoncé des
faillites en cascade et une catastrophe
économique avec notamment la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte qu'en est il réellement
la reprise économique est elle
finalement plus dynamique que prévu ce
sont les questions auxquelles on va
tenter de répondre dans cette émission
avec vous faut les vielles de la marche
bonjour olivier bonjour aux stocks face
à vous véronique riches florès bonjour
bonjour vous êtes économiste et
présidente de riches florès riecherts
bienvenue dans ces caches merci depuis
quelques semaines les bonnes nouvelles
s'enchaînent baisse du chômage
perspectives de croissance
encourageantes et le moral des ménages
qui repart à la hausse un regain
d'optimisme en france loin des
prévisions alarmistes du début d'année
explications avec le tiroir-caisse
d'antoine baisse
[Musique]
alors que les mesures du quoi qu'il en
coûte ont touché à leur fin on pouvait
craindre une énorme crise avec des
vagues de faillite de licenciement un
chômage qui explose et évidemment une
rigueur sèche pour rembourser les
milliards utilisés pour sauver
l'économie est pourtant du côté du
gouvernement en ce moment c'est plutôt
l'optimisme qui prime grâce à certains
chiffres en septembre le nombre de
déclarations d'embauché a frôlé les 840
milles parmi lesquels plus de 400 x et y
un seuil qui a été franchi trois fois
depuis juin la dernière fois c'était en
janvier 2006 ses dires et sur le
deuxième trimestre de 2021 c'est 2,44
millions dans bausch là le record
précédent était en janvier 2000 du côté
de bercy on a même réhausser la
croissance prévue pour cette année de
0,25 point à 6,1 25% et on prévoit
toujours un retour au niveau d'avant
crise en décembre de cette année avec un
déficit qui ne dépassera pas cinq pour
cent le gouverneur de la banque de
france fraîchement réélu par la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale sur recommandation du
président de la république va encore
plus loin il n'y aura pas de tsunami de
faillite au présent comme au futur
celles ci ont reculé de 25,1 % sur un an
bref l'apocalypse économique que
certains prédisaient à l'air d'être déjà
un lointain souvenir
à moins que à moins que l'effet de la
cessation des aides soit à retardement
et que les problèmes liés aux prix de
l'énergie ou à la pénurie de matières
premières ne vienne s'immiscer dans
toutes ces bonnes nouvelles faisons
ainsi changer le grand sourire actuelle
du gouvernement par une bonne vieille
grimace
[Musique]
le quoi qu'il en coûte on l'a dit touche
à sa fin a pourtant au vu de ces
chiffres que l'on vient de voir dans le
tiroir cash l'économie ne semble pas
plomber contrairement aux craintes que
l'arrêt des dispositifs dead avait
suscitées pourquoi olivier est ce que
finalement les chiffres sont beaucoup
plus positif que prévu parce que ce sont
des chiffres de qom sont des chiffres
politique donc évidemment on se réjouit
depuis déjà un bon bout de temps que
le taux de faillites est diminué mais le
taux de faillite il a diminué pourquoi
tout simplement parce que on a
subventionné
les entreprises et cela depuis le départ
c'est à dire qu'on a remplacé du chiffre
d'affaires phare de la dette et donc on
les a endetté et est aujourd'hui n'ont
pas commencé à rembourser et on a on a
entretenu des zombies si vous voulez
donc on a fait en sorte qu'il ne tombe
pas et donc là on peut évidemment se
réjouir qu'ils ne soient pas tomber moi
je pense que c'est une erreur mais bon
après que monsieur bruno le maire s'en
réjouissent je le comprends parfaitement
d'autant plus qu'on est à six mois des
élections donc il faut quand même se
réjouir de quelque chose maintenant si
vous voulez les les
ce qu'on appelait quoi qu'il en coûte à
changer non mais il reste qu'il qu'il y
a toujours des mesures d'accompagnement
dans beaucoup de secteurs qui a toujours
un soutien dans beaucoup de secteurs et
au niveau aussi de
de l'emploi et donc il ne faut pas
s'étonner que ça ne se voit pas écroulé
maintenant moi ce que j'attends c'est la
fin réelle des aides de l'état et la fin
réelle des aides de l'état risque d'être
un petit peu plus compliqué d'autant
plus qu' il y à un moment où les
entreprises vont être obligés de
rembourser une partie de ce qu'on leur a
donné à moins que ce soit un don
perpétuelle ça peut elle être aussi mai
mais donc ne vous étonnez pas il ya
toujours énormément d'argent qui est
déversée on a toujours des déficits
budgétaires hallucinant et donc il n'est
pas étonnant que les choses n'aillent
pas plus mal dès maintenant véronique
riches florès pour revenir sur les chais
vous êtes d'accord les colisée ce sont
des chiffres de communication des
chiffres politique
écoutez ya toujours beaucoup de façons
de présenter les chiffres et de lire les
statistiques économiques parce que sinon
on aurait beaucoup moins de deux sources
de débat d'ailleurs entre économistes 1
est effectivement alors on peut rappeler
une chose vous souvenez que la fin de
l'année dernière avait été celle du de
reprise après un premier semestre
extrêmement éprouvant effectivement on
ré ouvre les genres circulent consomme à
peu près normalement ça vous fait des
effets de rattrapage extraordinaire on
peut dire qu'à la fin de l'année
dernière l'essentiel de la croissance
convives pour cette année était déjà
fait c'est comme une entreprise qui dira
j'ai eu un super début d'année j'ai fait
mon année est bien de nous c'était
pareil la plupart des pays d'ailleurs à
la fin de l'année dernière on avait
quasiment fait notre année 2021 avec ce
qu'on appelle en économie des acquis
c'est à dire des choses qui sont faites
effectivement de l'ordre de en france je
crois qu'on était quasiment à quatre
pour cent donc à partir de là
effectivement c'est pas très difficile
on rajoute 2 % avec un rattrapage parce
qu'effectivement la consommation les
investissements etc ont été
limités pendant toutes ces périodes de
confinement et autres et et on peut
afficher des chiffres ils paraissent
mirobolant mais qui en fait sont très
loin de la réalité et des flux
économiques réels donc oui il y a
il y as de la communication
rappelez-vous en début d'année on nous
avait dépeint une économie chinoise en
plein boom avec une croissance soi
disant à 18% c'est parce qu'on part et
sur un an alors voilà il est il ya
beaucoup de d'erreurs de communication
et une communication qui un peu plus
volontariste qui va plutôt aller
chercher d'écouté flatteur alors ceci
étant dit ces chiffres sont pas
complètement faux parce que comme le
disait olivier nous sommes nous avons
encore une économie presque mondiale
sous perfusion sous perfusion d'action
des gouvernements qui n'arrêtent pas
finalement en réalité ça s'appelle
plutôt tout à fait quoi qu'il en coûte
effectivement ils programment dead sont
pas comparables à ce qu'on avait un nom
mais il ya encore beaucoup dead et
l'économie va tellement bien que vous
voyez que pour faire face aux chocs
redouter de l'impact de la hausse du
prix du pétrole ou des carburants on
revient vite à la charge avec un chèque
de 100 euros c'est peut-être que quand
même il ya des fragilités dont on nous
parle pas tout à fait mais qui
inquiètent beaux gréements et qui ont
raisons d'inquiéter parce
qu'effectivement il est sous jacent de
la croissance économique sont très loin
de correspondre aux chiffres
pharaoniques on affiche ya pas que la
france qui affiche chez ces chiffres là
c'est assez générales vous parlez tous
les deux deux chiffres est loin de la
réalité pourtant quand on regarde par
exemple l'emploi et les alex avec ce
record dans gauche au troisième
trimestre et les embauchant qui continue
de progresser l'insee table notamment
sur un taux de chômage à 7,6 et % c'est
moins que ces -0 28% par rapport au
second trimestre ce sont quand même des
données factuelles les olives et non
c'est pas des données factuelles c'est
toujours la même chose c'est à dire
c'est la manière de présenter les choses
donc on va vous on va vous sortir par
exemple les catégories a et on va vous
dire les catégories à
il ya 7 6% de chômage sauf que pas de
bol si vous voulez il ya 7 6% de chômage
si on considère la catégorie a si on
considère les catégories un petit peu
plus
réalise si vous voulez c'est à dire les
gens qui vont travailler deux heures par
semaine les gens qui vont être sortis
complètement des statistiques du chômage
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont là
pour le coup aux rsa et qui n'ont plus
du tout de 2,2 lien avec la la
statistique purs et durs du chômage
c'est à dire celui qui est inscrit au
chômage qui cherchent du boulot qui
s'inscrit tous les mois qui donnent bon
et c'est cette catégorie ya ne
représente absolument pas la masse de
chômeurs qu'il ya donc vous avez
d'autres
unités de mesure mais évidemment c'est
pas celle qu'on vous affiche parce que
celle qu'on vous affiche il faut montrer
et je vous dis cinq mois avant les
élections c'est mieux il faut montrer un
taux de chômage bas parce que sinon ça
veut dire que la politique qu'on a mené
est nul et non avenu donc que
comme par hasard je pense que les
catégories avons continué à baisser
jusqu aux élections puis après on verra
si ça remonte
il ya un vrai problème à considérer le
taux de chômage comme un indicateur
pertinent soit vous regardez les
créations d'emploi ça vous regarde et le
taux de participation parce qu'on le
sait nous c'est nos sociétés sont de
plus en plus exclusive de plus en plus
de gens capitule tout simplement à se
présenter est chez nous à pôle emploi
ailleurs dans les agences respectives ce
qui fait que ces gens là ne sont plus ne
sont qu'une ré statistiques qui ne sont
plus dans la vie économique d'ailleurs
et et on les capture pas alors j'irai il
ya c'est pas très difficile en réalité
de faire baisser le taux de chômage ait
suffit effectivement de jouer sur ce
terrain de l'exclusion un point un
gouvernement qui parviendra à faire
remonter le taux de participation
c'est-à-dire le pourcentage de personnes
en âge de travailler qui effectivement
sont à la recherche d'un emploi ou un
emploi encore mieux alors là il y aura
réussite et là il y aura conviction
qu'on est un peu mieux armés pour
affronter l'avenir notamment un avenir
d'une population vieillissante qui lui
aussi est plutôt à faire baisser le taux
de chômage merci on m'a marqué une
courte pause
bienvenue dans ses cages si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine la
fin du quoi qu'il en coûte va-t-on
assister un tsunami de faillite c'est la
question et pour y répondre et olivier
de la marque bien sûr et véronique
riches florès économiste et présidente
de riches florès reasearch les derniers
chiffres confirment une reprise forte de
l'économie française a déclaré le
gouverneur de la banque de france le 19
octobre dernier sur france info tous les
secteurs vont bien at il ajouté un
optimisme devrait afficher deux jours
plus tard lors de la convention annuelle
des correspondants tpe pme il n'y aura
pas de tsunami de faillite je le dis au
présent mais aussi au futur at il
déclaré selon les dernières statistiques
les défaillances d'entreprises elle
reste à un niveau très bas en france ou
moins 20 21 2% par rapport à septembre
2020 même son de cloche du côté du
ministre chargé des pme il n'y aura pas
de vague de faillites et de vagues de
licenciements massifs peut-on ans
peut-on en être aussi certains dernier
cas riche le reste ou est ce que
finalement les effets néfastes du quoi
qu'il en coûte vont finir par pointer le
bout de leur nez bien tant qu il un
temps qui a pas de pression sur les
gouvernements pour
ramener des déficits à des niveaux plus
soutenable en parle de 3% et a pas de
raison de se figer sur ce niveau là mais
tant que les gouvernements sont encore
largement financé par les banques
centrales finalement quoi qu'il en coûte
ou une version amoindri effectivement
peut continuer et il à partir de là a
pas de raison d'être outre mesure 1 kg
et effectivement on voit tout à fait la
réaction du gouvernement français comme
la plupart des gouvernements ces
derniers temps c'est quand même très
impressionnant de voir la peur par
rapport à l'échec par rapport à l' effet
d'annonce de faillites d'entreprises ou
autre donc ils sont tous effectivement
très près et à agir dès qu'il ya un
risque et et ils en ont toute la
latitude puisque les banques centrales
continuent pour l'instant at il demandé
chez à acheter massivement des
obligations d'entreprises donc tant
qu'on est des obligations d'état parle
tant qu'on est dans ce contexte là avec
des taux d'intérêt qui malgré tout reste
historiquement bas des taux d'intérêt
réels qui se sont effondrés quand on
compare à l'inflation dont on n'a
quasiment jamais connu de tels niveaux
de taux négatifs et bien ou pourquoi
voulez vous que les entreprises fassent
faillite de toute façon si on a une qui
tousse gouvernement va revenir à la
charge donc c'est plus tard que va se
poser la question et notamment un quand
il faudra rembourser effectivement les
dettes donc les pg e plus et recours aux
marchés qui ont été absolument
phénoménaux pour beaucoup dans de
nombreux cas quand même douteux sur la
soutenabilité et la solvabilité des
entreprises qui empruntent massivement
et très facilement
et deux là où ça moi je suis un peu plus
préoccupés enfin où je me pose vraiment
des questions c'est finalement une fois
qu'on a tous ces entreprises surendettés
qu'est ce qui va faire la reprise et en
particulier la reprise d'investissements
probablement pas les entreprises donc
les états sont à la manoeuvre avec des
plans de relance mais en réalité s'il
n'ya pas le relais de la part des
entreprises privées et bien tout ça va
faire flop or
si vous avancez des sommes colossales
comme on a avancé depuis deux ans dans
l'économie
la seule chance de pouvoir être crédible
à long terme et de garantir leur
remboursement c'est de retrouver des
fondamentaux économiques solides et on
est très loin de ce cas de figure là
alors on aura peut-être pas les clés
faillit pas outre mesure je pense pas
qu'il y ait une masse de faillite qui
nous menace dans les prochains mois
parce que je pense que les gouvernements
vont continuer tout simplement être très
présent mais ça veut pas dire pour
autant que la situation soit scène
olivier on va s'intéresser aux
prévisions des économistes de l'heure en
2022 selon eux les faillites devrait
bondir de 40% un phénomène qu'il
qualifie de début de normalisation
en cause des fameuses entreprises ont
envie de vous parler oui mais je suis
d'accord c'est à dire tant que le temps
que les banques centrales
inondent le marché vous n'aurez pas de
faillite
regardez il ya quelques jours c'est
typique hertz merde ce qui est une
entreprise en faillite totalement en
faillite comme en cent mille tesla
bon avec quoi avec l'argent qu'on lui
donne gratuitement d'accord donc vous
avez un système qui aujourd'hui
entretien des entreprises totalement
zombies qui ne qui n'ont absolument plus
lieu d'être mais on leur fournit de
l'argent pour qu'elle reste en activité
et que ça fasse un semblant de 2 mais
c'est un mirage de croissance si vous
voulez parce que en fait ils commandent
100000 tesla qu'on leur donne de
l'argent pour qu'ils puissent les payer
enfin on est dans un système
complètement schizophrénique face et
c'est donc à
nous demander combien de temps ça va
durer on n'en sait rien le temps que les
banques centrales continueront à jouer
ce jeu là et à mon avis elles n'ont
aucune raison d'arrêter puisque elles ne
sont elles sont loin d'être indépendante
s'est imbriqué avec les politiques et il
n'y a absolument aucune raison qu à un
moment
quelque quelle que soit la banque
centrale soit la fed la bce ou ou une
autre 10 fin de partie on arrête et
évidemment parce qu'ils savent que tout
le système repose là-dessus quand vous
avez une banque centrale comme la fed
elle ne peut pas aujourd'hui revenir en
arrière si elle a si elle arrête c'est
tous les fonds de pension qui s'écroule
ça veut dire qu'on ne paye plus aucune
retraite enfin vous avez quand même des
déchets des revers de la médaille on est
en train d'assister à aussi un revers de
la médaille de cette politique là qui
est lé plus gris sont les prix de
l'énergie ça fait partie alors il n'y a
pas que ça mais ça fait partie aussi de
la hausse des prix du pétrole de la
hausse des prix du prix des matières
premières c'est tout simplement l'argent
qu'on met dessus et comme ce sont des
produits qui sont financiarisé donc qui
sont cotées en bourse et donc qu'est ce
qui se passe bien il se passe tout
simplement que vous avez des des traders
vous avez des grands fonds qui investit
sur ces matières premières pour faire de
l'argent et donc vous avez une partie
spéculative dans le dans le coût des
matières premières qui est importante et
ça c'est le revers de ce que font les
banques centrales donc là aussi elles
sont un peu coincé c'est à dire soit
elle continue et à ce moment là vous
avez prennent et de l'énergie qui monte
et ça va impacter la la soi-disant
reprises et soit elle arrête là à ce
moment là c'est vous qui s'écroule donc
le le dilemme est cornélien
nous avons de reparler justement des
matières premières véronique riches
florès quand on tournait d'un côté un
optimisme exacerbé de l'autre on a des
prévisions comme celle de leurs avec
des mauvaises prévisions par exemple
l'année 2022 avec des filles qui vont
bondir finalement ça s'est traduit quoi
que personne n'en sais vraiment n'en
sais rien
alors deux d'un côté ça traduit
effectivement une volonté de communiquer
sur les aspects positifs et les chiffres
et le
les distorsions statistiques liées à ces
creux et ses rebonds permettent
effectivement d'alimenter un discours
plutôt positif de l'autre effectivement
on peut avoir des diagnostics beaucoup
plus négatif mais comme le disait
olivier là je suis complètement d'accord
aujourd'hui nous sommes au
aucun moyen de dire demain il va y avoir
une vague de faillites demain ou après
demain parce qu on est en lévitation
avec des gouvernements qui sont là et
met par exemple quand on leur fait ses
prévisions ils prennent pas en compte
par exemple et les politiques monétaires
des banques centrales ça veut dire que
l'air nous dit d'abord les politiques
des banques centrales sont peut-être en
train de changer 1 et leur nounou tire
la sonnette d'alarmé un petit peu comme
nous on le fait en dix ans le système
est pâtent nabili à une planche pourrie
et donc
il ya des risques de faillite là on peut
dire oui mais si on continue comme ça il
y aura pas de faillite d'accord mais le
risque il est bien là et le risque
effectivement c'est qu'on se rassure
alors qu'on est véritablement sur une
énorme planche pourrie mais qu'on
continue du coût du nuage
en restant lévitation je pense qu'on a
ça fait plus d'un an que l'économie
presque mondiale étant dans cette
situation de lévitation alors on peut le
comprendre le choc si on ne faisait rien
serait probablement tél bien évidemment
et pas question d'envisager qu'on laisse
tomber mais de là à voir un discours
rassurant comme si tout était normal et
si on avait un avenir garanti
rose est bien là je pense qu'il ya un
pas qu'il faut pas franchir parce que
les lendemains risquent de déchanter un
mois présent sur la crise que traverse
le secteur de l'énergie et des prix qui
flambent par exemple les tarifs
réglementés du gaz ont augmenté à dans
le pays de 8,7 pour cent au 1er
septembre au sein de l'ue que tous les
pays ne semblent pas s'accorder sur la
façon dont il faudrait répondre à cette
question bref elle fait un sujet
d'inquiétude olivier c'est un nouveau
bémol à la reprise économique
c'est un nouveau bémol oui c'est je vous
dis c'est la conséquence de ce que font
de ce que font les banques centrales et
puis c'est la conséquence aussi
de de comportement
mes anciens de comportement
de deux vallées des états unis on sait
très bien que on aurait pu si on avait
mis moins de sanctions par exemple sur
pour les russes et sur le gazoduc
qu'ils étaient en train de construire on
aurait peut-être dû gaz un petit peu
moins cher donc
on a une succession de bêtises on a une
succession de deux mauvaises
anticipations qui font que en plus de ça
puis vous avez l'europe qui bloque aussi
pas mal de choses au niveau des prix du
gaz qui sont liées aux prix de
l'électricité etc donc vous avez un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été mal
faites mal préparé mal anticipé on a
tout d'un coup on avait tout axé sur sur
les ventilateurs saleh les trucs que
j'aime bien et
et on avait arrêté totalement sous la
pression écologiste
que ce soit les allemands ou où nous de
construire des centrales nucléaires là
tout d'un coup monsieur macron
toujours toujours la même chose cinq
mois avant les élections se dit que
peut-être il faudrait construire
quelques centrales nucléaires sauf que
c'était il ya 10 ans ou 20 ans et il
fallait le faire parce que vous mettez
dix ans à construire une centrale est ce
qu est ce que concrètement ce qu'on vit
dans c'est ce que vit le secteur de
l'énergie aujourd'hui peut être va
freiner la reprise économique qui fait
mais ça va freiner aussi c'est à dire
que si vous avez une envolée
encore plus importante parce que pour
l'instant c'est que c'est très ciblée
sur le sur le gaz mais vous en avez pas
le pétrole est à 80 dollars c'est cher
mais c'est pas c'est pas encore délirant
mais si vous avez en effet si vous avez
une poursuite de cette hausse des
matières premières et pas que du pétrole
et du gaz vous en avez d'autres si vous
avez une poursuite de cette hausse des
matières premières ça va devenir
problématique parce que c'est gentil
d'aller mettre 1 1 un chèque de 100
balles mais faut voir pouvoir quand même
le le le la hure e-sante crétinerie de
ce geste vous avez des prix qui montent
parce que vous avez fait des erreurs
d'accord parce que l'état fait des
erreurs je vous rappelle que sur un plan
d'un 50 sur un prix de l'essence d'un 50
vous avez un euro de taxe vous avez un
euro de taxe
sur donc c'est pas les marges des
entreprises qui augmentent comme l'a dit
une certaine pompili madame pompili qui
nous disait que la marge des
distributeurs de ferait bien d'être
réduite c'est pas la marge des
distributeurs
c'est 0,15 centime d'accord c'est pas
bon c'est pas un euro et on eu on ne
baisse pas les taxes et ensuite on file
s'emballe à 38 millions de personnes 38
millions de personnes qui gagnent moins
de mille balles par mois et donc et on
nous parle d'une reprise extraordinaire
mais il ya quand même 38 millions c'est
à dire plus de la moitié des gens en
france qui gagne moins de deux mille
balles par mois et qui ont besoin d'un
chèque de 100 200 balles parce que
l'essence a monté il ya quand même
quelques petites questions à se poser
merci à dire un dernier mot à ses propos
véronique riches florès oui oui bah on
peut mesurer au niveau mondial même on
peut parler de facture pétrolière avant
le gaz un de gaz maintenant c'est un
marché également assez spéculatifs vous
avez eu à peu près les mêmes phénomènes
avant la crise de 2008 et puis après
puis ça s'éteint au bout de 18 12 18
mois donc on verra mais un on a sous
investis dans les énergies et dans les
énergies renouvelables bien évidemment
de la liquidité il n'y a rien de mieux
pour les marchés les matières premières
marches et les matières premières
toujours été spéculatifs et vont rester
spéculatifs maintenant il y en a un peu
d'autres il ya des bitcoin et c'est donc
peut-être ça fera un peu diversion mais
on le sait et à des effets toujours
spéculatif 3 on nous a parlé d'une
reprise schumpétérienne la reprise son
pétard yann c'est quoi on remplace ont
détruit pour remplacer notamment dans
l'automobile en gros on est en train de
nous promettre que d'ici 2040 aux rendre
à remplacer tout le parc automobile
mondial par des nouveaux véhicules
électriques donc ça veut dire des
besoins supposé en matières premières a
trop nomique à face à des problèmes
d'approvisionnement et de raréfaction de
la matière première en marche sur la
tête et donc on est face à des tags
contradictions comme celle là qui
bien évidemment se solde par ces
flambées de prix dans un environnement
très permissifs qui est celui de l'hyper
liquidités est-ce que ça aura un impact
conjoncturel assurément vous avez une
facture mondiale de pétrole qui a déjà
monté de 2 points l'équivalent de deux
points de pipe si on a un prix du
pétrole qui monte à 100 dollars est
aujourd'hui possible eh bien on
reprendra deux points de pib alors que
l'économie mondiale est là c'est même
pas les pays développés le reste du
monde notamment émergents est encore
très loin d'avoir récupéré une santé
économique
tout simplement donc oui c'est un coût
pour le consommateur et un coût pour la
d'économie mondiale qui est
incontournable merci beaucoup véronique
riches florès d'avoir été parmi nous
dans cette émission je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste et présidente de riches
florès reasearch olivier merci beaucoup
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous la
semaine prochaine en attendant pour voir
ou revoir nos précédents numéros rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
rt france point tv et n'oubliez pas de
réagir à cette émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag rt cash olivier
le dernier mot bien on marche sur la
tête et on est en lévitation attention à
la chute